[Musique]
on se trouve ici sur la place Hubert
coudan à Orsay au cœur du campus urbain
de Paris Saclay cette place est une des
centrales quartier en constitution avec
beaucoup de d'établissements
d'enseignements supérieurs à direct
proximité on a le pôle biology
pharmaceimi de l'université Paris-Saclay
le lieu de vie du CROUS
Polytech et le bâtiment d'enseignement
de la physique et donc le but pour le PA
Paris Saclay c'était de venir offrir aux
étudiants de ce secteur de nouveaux
usages sur cette place et de mettre en
valeur l'existant avec notamment les les
vestiges gallo-romains qui se trouvent
juste derrière moi dans ce cadre le plat
à Paris Saclay a lancé un dialogue
compétitif pour sélectionner un designer
pour produire des mobiliers sur mesure
pour cette place avec de nouveaux usages
à proposer aux étudiants
le projet colorbloc est une gamme de
mobilier urbain qui s'annonce par la
couleur pour rendre l'espace public
dynamique inclusif et actif il se
compose d'un ensemble de modules
fonctionnels qu'on peut configurer
ensemble pour répondre à des logiques
d'usage
et de contexte et territoire différents
sur le la ZAC du Moulon pour implanter
différentes configurations et alimenter
les besoins des
usagers donc on a hybridé tout un tas de
fonctions sur cette gamme qui sont de
l'éclairage du son une fontaine pour
boire des bancs pour se reposer des
plugs pour recharger son smartphone ou
son ordinateur on a aussi travaillé sur
la médiatisation
spécifiquement sur cette place des
vestiges au centre de la place avec un
travail avec tactile studio qui a conçu
des supports de médiation inclusifs en
rapport à la malvoyance au malentendants
et on a développé aussi un éclairage
manipulable depuis les mobiliers pour
éclairer soi-même les vestiges lorsque
il est un peu de pénombre ou le soir
d'été
donc nous on a travaillé avec le PA
Paris Saclay et Alexandre Moreau sur la
conception et la fabrication de cet
ensemble de mobiliers urbains
se démarque par rapport à ce qu'on a
l'habitude de faire habituellement par
son ses innovations et son originalité
déjà sur les le premier point qui est
important c'est le fait qu'on soit
multimaterio les éléments bas qui sont
en béton ultra haute performance qu'on a
fabriqué avec mobilume donc ça c'est
déjà une première spécificité ensuite
les éléments qui sont métalliques et
puis on a aussi tout un tas de
fonctionnalités donc on a embarqué un
certain nombre d'équipements électriques
électronique dans les mobiliers urbains
on a travaillé sur la couleur
donc c'est vraiment un caractère
innovant et je trouve que ça fait
vraiment écho à la personnalité du
quartier Paris Saclay avec toutes ces
universités tous ces chercheurs qui
travaillent dans le quartier on est
vraiment dans le même philosophie donc
nous on est particulièrement euro et
fier d'avoir pu participer à ce projet
avec pa Saclay et Alexandre moronoses
[Musique]